Tức Mí Cơ sật lời đất, lu quất ngập luật cuộc bộ sống mưa lớn tại Mắc Bộ,
tút tưởng chính phủ đã ban thành công định số bệnh bị yêu cầu các bộ.
Ngàn, địa phương hình chung trị hai các mĩnh pháp ứng phó hiệu quả bảo đậm án tổn tính mà,
tại sản nhân dân.
Công định nhân mại, nhiều địa phương đang trong quả trình sấp sếp lại đơn vị hành chính,
chuyển sác mùi hình chính quyền hai cấp, sau tình đối không được địa giãn đạn chỉ đạo,
đưa hành công tác phòng, chống thiên tay.
Thủ tự yêu cầu chủ tự kiếc bán nhân dân các tình thành phố bác bộ chỉ đạo theo dõi sói xác viến tử tiết,
chủ động phương an ứng phó với lú quét, sát lượng, ngọt ũm, tăng cường kiểm tra đe điều hồ đập.
Bộ nông nghiệp và mối triệu được sào theo dõi, dự báo, cùng có thung tiên kì thời về tình yên tử tiết,
thêm tay cho các bộ, ngành, địa phương và nhân dân biết để chủ động chiến khai công tác ứng phó.
Bộ công thường, bộ xây dự, bộ cuối phòng, bộ công an chủ động phối hợp vào đảm ăn toàn tất công chiến vô thủy địch,
hà tần ra thông, vi đọc lượng lượng kiểu tại chỗ, các cơ quan truyền thông được sào đầy mạnh tương truyền,
hướng giẫn kiến năng phòng trong tiên tay cho nhân dân. Cập nhé thông tiên dự báo, đưa tiên kì thời,
chính giá về giến biến tiên tay để nhân dân biết chủ động uống phó vụ hợp.